very hey guys welcome to the first ever
Google Academy hang out this launches
our student filmmaker Week which
culminates in the Student Academy Awards
on Saturday so today we have some
student chemie award winners some
screenwriters from our Google+ community
and sitting down with john august to ask
some questions about the creative
process as well as sort of launching
their career so the way it's going to
work today is that i'm going to
introduce the lovely john august then
we're going to have our folks inside our
chat introduce themselves and ask a
couple questions we'll do it a couple
times and then we'll roll up for the day
um awesome so I'm going to flip it to
John John you know from his
screenwriting work and and many
collaborations with tim burton including
Frankenweenie as well as his huge
podcast script notes and his very
popular blog that i read all the time um
so John I'm gonna let you take it away
thank you very much for having us hello
it's a pleasure to be here and it's
always been welcome are a student having
board focus and a community I talk a lot
about screenwriting up on the blog on
the podcast and says it's about can stay
interesting questions lied and legal on
video I'm happy to do it no I'm looking
forward to meeting you guys so what you
guys did it well so we can ask who you
all oh let's start with Gary okay hi I'm
Kerri I'm a first-year screen ready at
UCLA film school the graduate program
and I'm from Boston i was born in the
Soviet Union came here when I was four
years old and I was raised I was raised
in America so yeah I mostly i right most
trying to get more into television right
now into sort of comedy / dramedy and
I'm a big fan of script notes listen to
it to that a lot and yeah that's hope to
hear some more with awesome people
earners
Jenna hi I'm just introducing myself
right that's what we're doing first ok
cool so hi I'm Jenna was over I also go
to UCLA although I'm an undergraduate
screenwriting concentration I grew up in
Chicago I lived in portland oregon for a
couple years and moved down here nine
months ago and it's been a big switch I
come from a journalism background and
I'm really enjoying it though I've
always looked to write and it's been a
very positive experience and I'm so
happy to meet you and I also love script
notes thank you thank you great and then
we're gonna move over to Jonathan Oh
does it looks like your your mic is off
all right hey guy I'm Jonathan longer I
went to USC and my thesis film just
feeding the roach is one of the
narrative winners same canvas Jenna and
Brian apparently um yeah from Minnesota
to LA via New York yep that's me free
okay fair Lawrence Oh kind of cookie in
a no go ahead Gary okay uh so with the
San I start with a question or is it
okay um okay well this is kind of geared
about script notes and I don't know if
you I'm sure most of you are familiar
with it um basically my question is how
has script notes since you started doing
the podcast how has it in any way
influenced your your personal career as
a screenwriter have you gotten any like
more attention or more jobs or like when
you have meetings with executives are
they like oh you know i love the podcast
or or you know and i actually and
sometimes I notice you say stuff in and
I'm very surprised you say you and Craig
both talk about things in the podcast
that I'm like wow I can't believe
they're actually saying that public I'm
like wouldn't I get them in trouble with
somebody and so yeah I guess my question
is like over
since the podcast started how has that
sort of changed your your career great
so from people you know the podcast I
views about script notes it was pregnant
another screenwriter and we've been
doing it for ninety four episodes now we
do it every week and it was really a
chance to talk about some things that
i've been blogging about but a blog it
really is a monologue and as a chance to
actually die a lot about some things
because my opinion is my opinion but
it's not always necessarily the right
opinion and ela talk things through is
really really helpful um what's been
strangely so we have a model listeners
and so you know it's hard to keep really
good metrics on sort of a podcast cuz
it's all sort of a new form but about
200,000 people download the show every
week which is great so those can't all
be a starring on screeners I think it's
bronze be ocular student film overall um
what strange though is like I feel like
a lot of times people i'm meeting with
aren't we aren't listen to podcast and
so it's just sort of a whole separate
world so there's a bunch of people who
are aspiring screenwriters or who work
on TV saps who read our show listen to
our show but the actual executives were
meeting with generally have no idea that
i have a podcast or that this is
something that i'm doing on a weekly
basis where i've gotten a little out of
it it's just a chance to kind of set a
weekly therapist have some sort of talk
through the stuff that I'm going through
as a writer for how I feel about issues
and just good different perspective on
things i really enjoy especially the
three page challenge as we do where we
take people send in free pages that
their script and we'll look at them and
we'll talk throughs or what they're
doing in those free pages and really get
specific on craft stuff which is a hard
thing to do unless you have paper in
front of you to do it so i have gotten a
lot out of it cool that's fantastic
Jenna that's right so I actually have a
different question it's not about script
notes um I just have a very general
question which is kind of about starting
out I like Gary would also love to be
involved in writing for television I
love family dramas Six Feet Under and
The Sopranos totally like grab my heart
um I'm wondering what your insights are
especially after you know having just
moved here and I'm really just like
sinking starting to sink my teeth into
it did you ever feel like there was a
period of
life where you were sort of like
paralyzed by the fear of not being good
enough or like you knew how to craft
things like being like paralyzed by
being a perfectionist or something and
if so like how did you cut through that
well I think there's a key to date as
you go through there's that clear that
you're not good enough and there's that
moment which you sort of do kind of
break in you have some success and you
realize you have a fear of like oh no
I'm an imposter they're going to find
out that i'm actually not good enough
I'm gonna really go away yeah what is
great about television is held at least
has a track system and so there's a wage
where progress up through television is
so different than features features only
you could just be a spec writer for
forever and eventually sell something
and it sort of gets hired to do more
stuff whereas in TV you have sensitive
like are you on a track in television
because I Corey on a staff there's a
tradition of serving the writers
assistant in a room and eventually
getting that that one episode and then
getting hired as a staff writer as
you're working your way up through and
you can learn a lot because you're
surrounded by writers all the time and
features you're not surrounded by
writers and that's one of the reasons
why I've always sought out things like
the Austin Film Festival or other
chances just be around other features
screenwriters because we always work in
isolation absolutely a television you're
around other people all the time that's
amazing opportunity so yeah I I envy you
mostly because you're entering a time
when television when our dramas are the
best they've ever been and yeah if this
is the Golden Age of the one-hour drama
just I plead to you as an Academy member
make don't forget features because we
need your right features as well
absolutely yeah for sure thank you
that's fantastic Jonathan hi um I was
wondering if you could talk a little bit
about collaboration with directors you
know that because as a director
sometimes our dependency is to be very
controlling and but it's also like
important to keep in mind that you know
it's just to keep the creativity from
the screenwriter flowing freely and us
wondering
advice for directors on how to do that
yeah i'm not sure who said this
originally I credit Alan Ross McCadden
is very smart but there's others market
limits that it's too you have to
remember that the screenwriter is the
only person who's already seen the movie
and so you as a director yours to be on
your reading the script that's miter saw
the whole movie in his or her head and
so has a vision for what that is and the
challenge of collaborating with three
members and directors is having this
vision that's in one person's head and
sharing it into Google's heads and so if
your vision as a director is not with
the rear end vision is it's finding that
common ground so it fit both of your
heads the successful collaborations I've
had have talked less about the mess
about served me telling somebody telling
me how to write something and more what
wasn't working for them so I can give
them I can give them what they need and
I found as a directive movies as it
works with any department head as much
as I try you know I might know a fair
amount about editing or a fair amount
about cinematography but that's not my
forte so I try to talk in sort of
general terms of what I'm going for and
let them figure out how to give me what
I'm going for and in the same holds true
with three matters is making sure that
collaboration is recognizing what
they're going to be great at and letting
them come up with the solutions to the
issues that you're at it that's
fantastic um do you feel like there's a
significant are you going to direct more
do you feel like there's a significant
difference in time and an effort between
writing and directing have done the
luxury for screenwriters that i can
write for movies in a year and as a
director I could maybe direct half a
million a year and so as a person wants
to make a lot of stuff screenwriting is
a really good choice for me but I'm
never the final artist on any movie that
i right and also you know i can write
all these things that never become
movies and so I part of the reason why I
think of these passports directing soon
is that it's a chance to actually search
it finished and get finished the way you
want to get finished so I've loved
writing moves for other people but I'll
try writing something for myself now
which
holy this next year I'll get to direct
awesome tastic Gary we're gonna flip it
to you again all right um so my next
question is and I don't know if you've
gotten this one before I'm guessing you
have but I writer's block have you ever
gotten it um and how do you how do you
deal with it like some time you know
sometimes you just wake up one day and
you're just like I haven't I don't know
what I'm doing I have nothing to
contribute to this story i'm totally
confused everything's upside down how do
you how do you sort of fix that
situation if if you get it yeah yeah
I've never had that kind of writer's
block where you're seeing movies where
that they're sitting on typewriter
they're typing things with the dark and
stormy night and they rip it out what's
so weird is that we all have we see that
scene in so many movies and yet it's not
a big match like happens if we can real
life what would you what I do find said
most times I don't want to sit down and
write because I'd rather do almost
anything other than right because
writing stuff the writing is just
portraits to do a lot of times
especially starting to writers portraits
and yet we romanticize writer's block
because we don't talk about accountants
block or you know um secretaries walk
but there's a lot of judge and you don't
sort of really want to go do them but
you know you have to go do that um where
I found it's helpful is to focus on
little small things that can achieve and
so sometimes that means I mean I want to
tackle a giant scene but I'll tackle
that little too easy little scene which
is for walking character through a door
I'll just get started that way the plots
of techniques are always when you are
finding good stuff when writing is
flowing really well to stop when you saw
a little bit left in the tank I'll often
sort of beat out the next couple things
are happening with scenes ahead so that
when i get started the next time I'm not
staring at a blank you know section of
screen actually have some stuff in there
to fill in but it's hard every time
every time I start to write a new script
I think I'm never going to finish it and
that's that never goes away oh and just
a follow-up question to that awesome do
you have like a like a writing do you
like a sketch schedule / say like you
know certain amount of hours per day
that you work every day or is kind of
sporadic I'm in my office from 10 to six
but
I don't spend the whole time writing i'm
doing a lot of other stuff and part of
reason why i do the podcast and blog and
so i can have an excuse for why i'm in
the office rather than spending time
with my family um what what I do find is
what I'm really writing on something I
will try to keep a little bit more
regular hours and i'll try to biscuit 77
page count so i'll say like I'm gonna
write five pages every day and I
sometimes will resort to the terrible
tricks were like I'm a head contract to
myself but I don't write five pages
every day for these this whole week then
i will donate money to a horrible
charity or so just do something no I
I'll make it bad on myself I don't do
that because sometimes writing is just
wonderful lovely it's a fantastic
process but sometimes it is just awful
work and I do find if I write the
endings of things pretty early in the
process it's much easier for me to fill
in for to the middle I know that look
it's done I won't have that panic about
how this is possible this is all been
resolved that's fantastic i love that
you have to give money to a horrible
charity and I secretly want that list
after this Google hangout is over also
if anyone wants to do that there's a
secret to do it is that you can actually
donate anonymously through other sort of
there was a little never get traced back
to me and I always have to offset that
donation to like the equivalent good
charity it's just it's not a son of
healthy thing I do but it gets it's got
some things written that is awesome
danna what's your next question um so
Mike what actually I had the writer's
block question but I had another
question that somewhat similar which is
something that you touched on earlier uh
what do you do about being in isolation
like how do you craft things that are
big hearted and genuine and real because
I know that you do because big fish
makes me cry every time no no question
so how do you do it like how do you kind
of like reverse engineer human emotions
well isolated um I'm very method in a
way that I wouldn't have expected as a
kid but for a big fish for example I
made myself fry and so I would sit in
front of mirror and bring myself to
tears and I wrote through those last you
know 15 pages of the script and it was
little just
you know it was a week of sort of like
telling everything I loved and sorting
those tears out and um it wit came
through it and stuff that I've written
that's really scary I tended to terrify
myself and then right what that felt
like and so you try to capture that the
feeling of being that emotional being
that scared in in the writing I and then
you just you know you let people read it
and that's the most terrifying thing
about writing it because it's such an
you know solo process yeah eventually
you have to share with people you have
to see whether it works in their head
what film I works in your head and
eventually you know if you discover
what's going to work what's not going to
work but even you know 20 years into
this I don't always know and there's
things which I I'm convinced are going
to work exactly the way I want them to
work and it is don't land for people
that's red that's an awesome answer
thank you I can't believe that that's
how the end of big fish was written now
I know we're doing the Broadway musical
version of a [ __ ] right now yeah get
through those last sections my first
time really collaborating with somebody
on a writing project and so Andrew
lipidic there's suppose when I I finally
decided on it likes it Andrew we're
gonna start talking and we're start
crying and then we're gonna write that
last song and and that's how he did it
and it worked and it's an amazing moment
in the show but I think it's because we
were feeling what we need to be feeling
as we were writing for sure it's super
awesome thank you is adapting big fish
for the musical version a lot different
than sort of writing it as as a movie or
is it is this your first musical this is
my first stage musical so I've done um
Charlie Chocolate Factory I've really
needs a goal of corpse bride and even
the original big fish i had a musical
number in there with i wrote this is the
first time writing for the stage and
it's been great it's been much more
collaborative than i've ever had to deal
with in mostly the best awful ways the
challenge is that I it's never finished
and so at least with a script you've
done for a while and they can move on
something else or with a movie you have
your cut and like you can show that
kappa then eventually you're finished
and I've
the term about the elders never be
finished with big fish because we're
down during your visions before we go to
Broadway in the fall and even we're open
on Broadway and success will have to
figure out what it's like when it's for
if it doesn't see why they didn't like
figure out sort of what the nation of it
is and that's a challenge to even as we
had it on stage in Chicago for five
weeks we were making changeable on the
way and it's like trying to fix the
train is moving 100 miles per hour it
was completely different skill set they
don't want you to possibly death at a
question about um representation I'm
kind of pin to the point where I'd been
to you know kind of chose to manager but
now I need to figure out which agent to
go with so I was wondering if you had
any advice on that like what to keep in
mind and what to expect once you do get
an agent I would remind you that these
are agents and managers lawyers or
people you're gonna have to deal with
for years and so make sure they're
people you want to be on the phone with
and that you want to have in your life
because sometimes you feel like well I
want the big scariest age and you can
possibly get well you don't want it an
agent who you don't actually want
representing you doesn't feel like
someone would want to invite into your
home um it doesn't it keep in mind is
that agents and managers they're there
to help put you in room to talk with
people and sort of get you started on
projects and get you meeting people but
they're not actually making movies and
they're not actually going to be getting
jobs what they're going to be doing is
sort of establishing relationships and
negotiating contracts but you are
responsible for your own destiny and
whatever you want to make whatever you
want to work on it's going to be your
decisions and your relationships that
make that happen not someone elses well
that is incredibly helpful and I think
we're actually going to wrap up for the
day or we will hang out thank you very
much for being part of it everything
worked with technically perfectly man is
fantastic and done thank you so much for
spending time with us this morning and
the advice you gave to the kids was
fantastic thanks guys for hanging in the
hang out with us thank you see it
thanks a lot me thanks alright thank you
just come back thursday for art hang out
with Jennifer Todd and I will see the
rest of these student kami award winners
here and town this Saturday excess